so those of you to the crash course
really like kept our house and
everything I can tell from his questions
that he was trying to fail and he said
his energy was negative and when I'm
backstage I'm often signing deals by the
way so I'm like backstage just before
two solid deals for come on stage I was
about to sign a lease option agreement
no money down I had a pound a month no
money down perfect lease option
agreement brilliant deal and I was about
to sign it
and I just had this very strange urge I
know through some god or just I don't
know what but to not sign the deal but
to let this negative person who was at
my event with his arms crossed let's
have this free house and I just asked
why that's at the bottom I'll go talk to
him giving this house and then took me
backstage I said hey Samuel is good it's
deal it's a lease option agreement no
money down here's the contract and Simon
said he wants to give it to you he was
just like why why why why why me all
this and I came in I was like dude I
just want to give it to you as a gift
it's all good no strings attached and
was like listen I want to do it you know
that's really kind of you but let me
just think it over and let me just read
over the contract I'm a fair enough
as it does no problem I said go read
over the contract and I'll see you the
next breaking a couple of hours why must
be to you come on I was like it comes
back I'm going to do other stuff that
contract is a yeah I understand the
contract I said great I gave him the pen
and he was just a girl and I can't
repeat myself over and over and over
again everything's paid for the
contracts been paid for there's no down
payment it's a free house there's a
three-month black break floor so after
three months if you know it's not
working you can walk away and the
profits gonna be eight hundred pounds a
month and it's just like he says look
I'm definitely gonna do but look it
obviously it's a big decision can you
just give me till dinner
I like all right whatever
I see we do it cuz lucky then that goes
backstage with Ryan Brussels around as
well Russell senior CEOs all my brother
CEO the company most straight line
direct honest integrity driven person
who ever made
that whistle is like the foundational
good we've got you man he's like goes
off comes back at dinnertime Chester was
still just a boy he's in there like an
hour and a half comes back out I'm on
stage at this point comes back out and I
see come in and sit back at the back and
I look at Russell and look at Brian and
they look at me and I'm like oh like
good and they just go I go what's
happening what's going on he says yeah
I'm good you're really excited it's all
grand what what did you sign it not even
start because the thing is I have this
rule he said I have this raw which is
before I make any business decision I
have to have a face-to-face meeting with
my wife I was like okay I said you want
to call it out don't me to speak to her
spiritual she knows everything but just
whatever face to my smart answer guys
come with me cooling cool air
took him backstage and I kicked his not
includes us
I took you I still came backstage and I
got the contract and I got the pen and I
saw it and he looked like robbed you
know like I just like as if I'd now just
stolen from him I said this is why
you're broke and this is why you'll
always be broke so I said to be honest
with respect I'd probably leave the
crash course at this point because until
you sort this out you're never going to
be successful anyway you're wasting your
time you wasted my time
off you go good job
I'm sure you
[Music]